(film reeling)
- [Johnny] If you were able to
look through the perspective
of a person who thinks the world is flat,
you would see this.
The North pole is right
here in the center,
the continent's splayed
out over this plane.
And here on the edges, you'd
run into 150 foot wall of ice,
guarded by NASA employees with guns.
- [Recorded Speaker] And how
far that ice goes outwards.
And, when people have
tried to go down there,
they get turned away at
gunpoint and put in prison.
- [Johnny] The heavens are a dome
that arcs over the flat earth.
The sun, the moon, the stars,
they're all just little
balls of light in the sky
that move around just
above the earth's surface.
There are loads of people
who actually believe this.
YouTube channels and Facebook pages.
You'll see hundreds of
thousands of followers.
Google searches for the
term flat earth proof
over time look like this.
It's become incredibly popular.
And recently, a poll showed that only 84%
of Americans agree with the statement,
"I have always believed
the world is round", 84%.
And if you're 18 to 24,
that's more like 66%,
which is like dangerously close to half.
What is going on here?
- Now, the North Pole,
is the center of a deep ocean.
Whereas the South Pole,
is the center of a high plateau,
which averages seven or eight
thousand feet in altitude.
This is frustrating!
And, what's even more frustrating
is every time I try to look into this
and understand it, all I see is coverage
of like, flat earther conventions
and like, interviews with these people.
- We absolutely know for
a fact this ain't it.
- These interviews are interesting.
but I wanna understand like,
how someone with a thinking brain
can actually get behind this.
What is this actual belief?
Where does it come from?
And, how do potentially millions of people
believe that the earth is flat?
- [Recorded Male Speaker]
The water is completely flat
as far as we can see and
as far as we've measured,
and the horizon is completely flat.
- I'm in Mexico now.
I've been sitting on the beach,
reading everything there is to read
about the history of people
who believe the earth is flat.
There's one thing that I
just had to try for myself.
This is a simple experiment
that anybody can conduct
to determine definitely
that the earth is flat.
Grab a spirit level and
take it on a plane with you.
(speaking Spanish)
- Found this hardware store,
bought myself a level.
Gracias amigo.
- One of the stranger
things we've ever done.
- And I'm bringing it
with me on the airplane.
I'm gonna do some of this
empirical science myself.
If you are to fly on a non rotating earth,
please explain what kind of experience
will a pilot really have?
The logic goes
that if the earth is round
and I'm flying thousands of miles,
which I'm about to do,
then the airplane will have
to be tipped a little bit
the whole time in order to make it
around the curvature of the earth.
- The plane should be constantly
dipping its nose forward
in order to compensate for the curvature.
- Show me some planes doing this!
- I would be able to see
the tilt of the airplane.
If I put my newly purchased level
on the tray table in front of me.
- I'm gonna take my spirit
level onto the plane.
- If my tool shows me that
the plane is totally leveled-
- That's proof that the earth is flat.
- Let's go see what happens.
Can somebody explain to me, duty free?
Why perfume?
Why is there so much perfume in duty free?
Four hours on an airplane and I'm back.
My little level experiment
worked wonderfully.
The bubble stayed nice and center,
turns out the plane was
not dipping its nose
in order to (laughs)
make it around the earth.
This is explained by the
basics of gravity and physics.
This video is not a debunk
of flat earth theory.
That doesn't need to happen!
That shouldn't need to happen!
What this is, is my fascination
with the fact that
there is lots of people.
Let's put it this way,
a non zero number of humans
who think the world is flat!
And, they work really hard to prove it.
I wanna understand what sorts of tools
are being used to prove the world is flat.
So, here we go.
(spacey music)
I wonder if I can get some really dramatic
like, conspiracy theory
lighting going on here.
I've seen all the evidence.
What if the earth actually is flat?
The plane wasn't dipping,
the level was flat.
Okay, I'm kidding!
Let's get into this.
I've been in the weeds,
learning about the flat earth experience,
what people believe and why,
and where it all came from.
And, here's what I've learned.
Number one, flat earthers
have become a thing
just in the past couple hundred years.
So, by like 205 BC, you've
got these really smart
Greek people making experiments that are
like, observing a globe shaped earth.
Over the next several centuries,
eventually this would just
become the widespread thing
among anyone who was doing
experimentation on the world.
And eventually, nobody
believed the earth was flat.
Even in like the medieval times.
Like, it was a consensus
that the earth was a globe.
So in short, flat
earthers, weren't a thing
during this time, even though literally,
in elementary school, I was
taught that Christopher Columbus
and like, his voyage was somehow to prove
that the earth was round
or maybe it was flat.
And that there was like,
some debate around that.
That's actually a total legend!
And, I have no idea why I was taught that
in elementary school.
How did that happen?
I actually am genuinely curious,
like, how did that happen?
The fact is Christopher
Columbus, the Catholic church,
the Spanish patrons, no one
thought the earth was flat
but then they became a thing, any sort
of flat earther movement
didn't actually come around
ironically until science was
really starting to heat up.
During the mid 1800s a huge amount
of scientific breakthrough was happening.
The scientific method was taking off
and huge breakthroughs in biology,
physics, anatomy, and
mathematics were taking place.
But, at the time there were also people
who were becoming
uncomfortable with how advanced
scientific methods we're getting.
These guys were like, "Hold on a second.
"You have all these fancy
new tools to inquire
"into the world and to understand reality.
"But, these tools are getting like,
"too sophisticated and too
abstract and theoretical.
"They're becoming too disconnected
"from like, what I can see and understand
"and touch and feel."
They wanted to bring science back
to what it had been
for a really long time,
which is that like, a person
goes out, uses simple tools
like a telescope to look at the world
and to make conclusions
about how the world works.
So, it's the 1800s,
science is like, having it's time.
And, you have these
guys, usually from like,
the U.S. and the UK who want to throw out
this growing body of like,
amazing advancements in science.
And they start to do experiments.
Here's what those experiments looked like.
(upbeat music)
So, it's the summer of 1838,
England up in the County
of Cambridgeshire,
which literally sounds like a place
in the Lord of the rings.
So, it's the summer of 1838.
And, the Atom had just been discovered
and the Doppler effect is
like, being flushed out.
And then, you've got this guy,
his name is Samuel Rowbotham,
but he goes by the pseudonym Parallax,
which is actually a pretty dope name.
Like, if I were a DJ, I would totally
go with like, Parallax!
Anyway, Parallax decides,
even though all this science is happening,
he thinks it's time to
reopen up the debate
about whether or not the earth is a globe,
which was like literally settled
thousands of years earlier.
But he's like, "No, let's do it!"
And, he finds this canal system
that is incredibly straight.
This canal goes on for
almost 10 kilometers,
like six miles of just a straight line.
This guy says, "If the earth is a globe
"and people say it's 25,000
miles in circumference,
"then if I look at a straight line,
"after the first mile the
curvature of the earth would mean
"that the canal would now
be eight inches lower.
"After two miles, it
would be 32 inches lower.
"After three miles, 72 inches lower."
Meaning like, six feet,
almost two meters and so on.
So, he thinks eventually
the dip from the curvature
of the earth would be so great
that you could easily observe it.
(puzzling music)
So, he gets in the water,
he puts a telescope right above
the surface of the water
and then puts a boat on the canal
with a one meter tall post on it.
So, what he wants to see is
if the earth is curved, if it's a globe,
this post will start to
disappear over the horizon.
So, he does it.
The boat goes away.
It goes the entire six miles
of the canal and it stays
in sight the entire time.
It doesn't dip over the horizon.
And, he's stoked!
He's like, "Man, I just
proved that the earth is flat.
"And I did it with a
telescope and a boat."
Like, screw you science!
Like, I'm making breakthroughs
right here in Cambridgeshire!
And then, he writes this book,
where he flushes out this experiment
and several others that he does.
But wait, this experiment's like,
kind of legit, right?
It adds up, like his
numbers were all correct
about the circumference
and the dip of a curvature.
Like, why didn't it dip?
Like, why was the boat still in sight?
There's nothing wrong
with this experiment.
Parallax, got that great name!
Maybe he was on to something!
(beep)
No, no, this is stupid!
This is like a third
grade science experiment
in your backyard!
This experiment doesn't take into account
how the natural world actually works
and how light behaves
and refracts based on the
different air densities!
This is like stuff that
people already figured out.
And like, Parallax is
sitting there getting wet
in a canal, like trying
to observe this on.
No, this does not prove anything!
But Parallax didn't
wanna hear any of this.
He didn't wanna talk about
atmospheric refraction
and air density and how light
behaves in different media.
Too complicated, too abstract.
You can't touch and feel that stuff.
Instead, Parallax sees
science and observing reality
as a much simpler task.
In his book, he says, "Nature speaks to us
"in a peculiar language, in
the language of phenomenon.
"She answers at all times the questions
which are put to her."
Just like, go out and like,
put a question to mother
nature and she'll answer it.
As scientific methods
become more sophisticated,
they become harder for
you and me to understand.
Parallax and his canal experiments are
a reaction to all of this.
They are a call for a simplification
of scientific methods and
to return of the senses
as the primary force for
understanding reality.
He called his method of
reductionist pseudoscience
the Zetetic method.
He says that honesty of thought
is to look at truth in the face,
not the side face, but the full front.
Like, just like look at it,
go out and observe it for yourself.
He was among several scientists
and mathematicians at the time
who were on this train of
let's use really simplified reductionist
math and science to prove that
the earth is actually flat.
This argument of the flat earth
flickered for a little bit in the 1800s,
gained a little bit of traction,
but then eventually it died out,
until just a few years ago.
- I refuse to be another vegetable.
Pseudoscience garbage will
to me be unacceptable.
Anyone with eyes to see
don't have to be susceptible.
Dispose of your globe in the
nearest waste receptacle.
- There is no curvature to this earth.
There is no motion to this earth.
- If you just accept the globe
model with no understanding
of the flat and no clear
evidence for the ball earth,
do you see the problem there?
- Flat earthers are back
and their methods are very similar
to what Parallax was doing in the 1800s.
- And this is data!
This is repeatable,
observable, measurable!
- If you take the time to learn,
you will change your mind.
There's no doubt.
The only reason people think
they live on a spinning
ball is willful ignorance.
- They're still zooming into horizons,
but now they have hoards of visual stuff
to play around with.
They now have airplanes.
They now have satellite
imagery to play around with.
They now have the moon landing to dissect.
And now, they're taking levels
onto airplanes, like I did.
- Your plane can't go upside down!
Here's the thing, globe hugger!
- Like the flat earthers in the 1800s,
the flat earthers today want
to use their own intuition
and senses to understand reality.
And in the process, they reject and ignore
the huge body of science
that we all live with today.
- So, people that have physics
degrees, astronomy degrees,
they got their degree by regurgitating
what their teacher or the books told them.
- Instead of trigonometry, and telescopes,
and canals, the flat
earthers was today use videos
and photos circulated on the internet.
- The isothermal
equidistant projection map
that the U.S. GS actually uses
is the flat earth map.
- Wait, did he just say
isothermal equidistant projection,
that's like my favorite projection.
Is that the flat earth map?
Don't (silence) with me and projections,
I take them very seriously!
In true internet fashion,
this new current movement of flat earthers
has become just a bunch of
bumper sticker type assertions
and images that are really easy to share.
Just like Parallax's experiments,
these methodologies completely ignore
the way the natural
world is observed to work
by like, thousands of years
of scientific consensus.
But, if you go to the FAQ
page of the Flat Earth Society
you'll see what they're after here.
They believe that evidence is, quote,
"Relying on your own senses
to discern the true nature
of the world around us."
That's the best evidence.
And in that vein, that's
what these people are doing.
- I mean, so in the physics world today,
do they not understand that convex lenses
or fish eye lenses or
GoPro add a distorted view?
- So, what have I
learned from all of this?
From my understanding,
the flat earther movement,
whether from the 1800s
or today on the internet
is actually not totally
about the shape of the earth.
This movement has a much
broader message built into it.
There's a reason why 1984 is like,
in the cannon of the
flat earther movement.
1984 has nothing to do with
the shape of the earth.
What it does have to do
with is being skeptical
of big institutions that
are probably watching you,
that are probably controlling your life,
that are probably feeding
you bad information
to retain power.
- Well, we're not crazy,
we're just sick of the lies.
- Here's the thing,
most of the knowledge we
have about the natural world
and the universe, we've never seen.
We've never seen exoplanets
or the deep space telescopes
that tell us so much about our universe.
Instead, we read about this stuff.
We benefit from its findings.
We pay our taxes to fund more of it.
Science is like a tall tower
and each individual
researcher and institution
adds a little brick to that tower.
Each brick resting on the one below it.
No one person sees or
understands all of the bricks.
Instead, we have a system of debate,
reviews, scrutiny that only allows
the most accurate information
to be added to the tower.
And honestly, I don't think
humans are well suited
to adapt to this very impersonal way
of understanding the world.
We have evolved over millions of years
with our senses as our
main driver of survival.
And now, we live in a society
that is run by big systems
and impersonal institutions
that we will never touch
and feel, much less understand.
And that's why we have people
who believe the world is flat,
despite conclusive
evidence to the contrary.
This belief is a proxy
for a much larger paradigm
that mistrusts anything that
you can't touch and feel.
And so, yeah, I'm really
sad that only 84% of people
can say with certainty that
they've always believed
that the world is a globe.
And that's 64% for younger
people, only 64% of people.
Like that, that just blows my mind!
And, it's incredibly sad!
But, despite this belief, this movement,
these conventions, this total lunacy,
science will continue to do its thing.
It will continue to go
out, observe the world
with these amazing tools that we have,
come back, debate it, and add
to this tower of knowledge
that helps us see the
world as it really is.
I wanna thank Skillshare
for sponsoring this video.
Skillshare is this
amazing giant repository
of online tutorials where you can learn
everything you can
imagine, from photography,
to design, to illustration,
to character animation,
to filmmaking, to
entrepreneurship, all the things,
and you get unlimited
access to the entire library
if you subscribe.
You get two months free to Skillshare
if you click the link in my description.
You should check out this course
on the fundamentals of photo editing.
Photo editing is truly a craft.
And with a little bit of training,
you can dramatically
change how your photos look
and feel, both from just
simple mobile photography,
all the way to advance
professional photography.
Having these fundamentals in your toolkit
will help you make better images.
So, click the link in the description
to sign up for two months for free.
Like, you literally don't
pay any money for two months.
You can test it out
and see if you like it.
After that, I think it's like,
less than 10 bucks a month if
you subscribe to the yearly,
which 10 bucks, like 10 bucks
to have access to this giant
repository of tutorials
is like a no brainer to me!
So, I love Skillshare!
I love internet learning!
Go check it out!
Thank you for watching this video!
And, I'll be back soon
with some more stuff.
See you!
(mellow music)